how come resume welcome back
I mean to get simulator so the game just
came out there have some new goats to
play with well let's check them out
oh I look the same breakdance if you
like forty pie sorry I'm gonna try
something else in character can can we
please nope move by licking my tongue
goes to space if I lick it my tongue
becomes a laser have I you know better
than this - Victor stop freezing air we
got
oh [ __ ] what happened oh my god man
[ __ ] oh jeez Jennifer I love you wait
for me
just kidding I'm not that disc why does
my tongue go to space every time I lick
you man
let's go bouncy bouncy Jenny I'm sorry
identify you're too fat to bounce shut
up
the question the laws of physics come
here
don't fight it don't fight it - you
little fatty fatty oh jeez Danny party
jam
I'm not scared by a goat game room you
got so scared he fainted let's try out
some more guts
alright what else we got hey devil go
tweet right there is one thing with the
demagogue I missed though so you might
as well do that first I'm just saying
alright so if you press are things are
supposed to go okay let's not thank you
the game is gonna crash you I do that
that's right I got it
why does my head get stuck in there why
did not Jesus
Oh reach for the stars or Jesus might
become fine so we're gonna fight stop
saying Jesus okay all right from that
this on onward at this point English Oh
Jake what I even said it I can't okay so
no more swearing you no more Jesus
Christ all right
maybe now we can finally [ __ ] this get
maybe now finally I can mess this guy up
really no stop it
they were knowledge is this is katamari
goat edition I mean holy I mean what are
we doing
I'm pretty sure this is what lovemaking
we're making a baby this is a very rare
sight with the goats
really really well what's going on there
guys what are you doing hey hey I'm like
this is against that's right
round two best fight ever
I think I won that one do you have a
GoPro
even Oprah oh come on yeah I'm the
sexiest go to lap behave goat you go bra
bra how about slip that I know I know
all right now now Jess oh [ __ ] I mean
now push him out gently why I did it
aleksander Gustafson while you are
working
ding ding dong yeah worship me
I said worship me whoa whoa whoa oh not
that my oh my god I got my personal
Miley Cyrus ball go to ball it's like
pokemons but even better now that's
impossible
all right let's get it more football now
okay my god no don't get sucked down no
no I try to avoid this I really looks
like an epic battle or something
okay I got it let go come on
where am I now I fell off the game doing
no no yeah goat crashed Wow there's an
achievement for crashing the game best
game ever lick the hanging glider oh ok
let's do that one then oh god I got
stuck in that [ __ ] ah that's what he
say I wish you could climb them a little
faster I mean as money I appreciate
staring at a goat's ass all day long I
got better things to do okay
you don't believe me doing well let me
pin de dice it's okay goat did I do it
yes now if you start a vortex Oh
goddammit
don't start war
hey guys what kind of barbecue is that
I'm so sorry
there you go I fixed you oh god he's
getting sucked in
oh god I'm vortexing everything in the
room she's still typing of course Oh God
let's create one in here and let's see
what happens yeah just enough normal
they have being a goat I think they see
here let's create as big of a pile as
possible
oh and there we go Oh are you okay man
God am I gonna have to censor this video
now that was the devil go now this the
RIP goat what in them what oh do you
even GoPro someone explain to me what's
the point of ripped goat oh okay that's
what happened Oh nailed it okay what
else did we get angel goat since when
did I get an angel why did all these
goats can fame ah what is the point of
angel goat can I fly or something I mean
it's pretty awesome but you know what
let's try the boulder on the hillbilly
maybe that would work
Jennifer you [ __ ] I need your help oh
here we go here we go here we go
yeah dodge this Beach robot goat oh whoa
I'm a robe a how's it I'm not about this
I get the ostrich I get the giraffe but
this is just too far back it's just few
how dad you're not fine girl don't you
know who I am maybe I have to go back
here as an angel goat or something
hello they still worship me goats for
the goat some the goat queen okay whoa
whoa how did I do that okay so that's my
power I can like Oh
blieden Shh in front of flip so oh it's
so very even front flip
look at me now Oh Tufano go down oh go
Donald
all right go to the hill baby all right
let's jump here
it's not called flying it's gliding with
style that good so good right now
Oh go go go go go go go go
i'ma go go go go go go go go get it get
it get it get it get it get it go go go
go go go go balls yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah got got balls
yeah yeah yeah get get get up foul and
got no Cup balls bad I'm flying like a
ain't nobody stopping when goatee
goalies poppin nobody Kelly's poppin
girl who needs legs to walk anyway this
is how I wake walk out at the bed in the
morning
Italian dinosaur goat sounds great I am
very disappointed what the holidays well
come on really at least give me a
dinosaur I poop that an egg
oh no that's in melon hey watch
can I pick the right goat oh it's a
Joshy go but he probably couldn't keep
the name whoa whoa go it all the way
across the sky yeah so intense bounce a
hundred times on mattresses within six
30 seconds all right
what is Baby Doe mattress area [ __ ]
under mattress master baby I'm so sorry
so apparently if you press one it will
by yeah oh my god I finally got it
awesome thing to go to you're not a go
whoa what happened there notice me
senpai said notice me if I scream toe
maybe I will be cool front flip
nailed it alright so we're back to my
spirit animal there's one thing I want
to try with this guy
that's of 160 Tom man oh god what
happened
shred milling what am i doing I'm sorry
anything I click he just got this is
what happens when you started really
child I gave him that it's already made
to be glitchy man what the hell yes my
dream is true dreams are coming true I
always wanted to be a giraffe flying it
doesn't sound very healthy I don't know
what's going on here alright and by that
we have this episode Oh No hope you boys
enjoy watching as always leave a like if
you did it really helps me out a lot and
I really do appreciate it thanks so
thank you anyway that's all for me for
now since this guy come over today let
me Bruce